a judge dropped the most severe charges
tied to a hazing related death at a Penn
State fraternity he dismissed
involuntary manslaughter charges against
five former Beta Theta Pi members linked
to Timothy Piazza's death the 19 year
old died last year from head injuries
that for a night of heavy drinking at a
pledge event Latimer duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn spoke with
piazzas family after the decision glad
good morning good morning this was the
second time a judge decided to throw the
involuntary manslaughter charges out so
the piazzas weren't shocked but Evelyn
Piazza told us she was hopeful I guess
the judge just didn't see it that way we
didn't want to change his mind we
visited Jim and Evelyn Piazza last night
hours after a judge dismissed all
involuntary manslaughter charges in
their son Timothy's deadly hazing case
former Beta Theta Pi fraternity member
Daniel Casey is among those to have the
charge dropped in a statement to CBS
News KC's attorney called the
involuntary manslaughter filings a
mistake do you think it was an overreach
to go for some of these charges I don't
you don't know I don't Casey and his
former fraternity brother Brendan young
are still charged with conspiracy to
commit hazing 24 others face charges all
of which include jail time this is no
longer just a hazing case this is a
conspiracy to commit hazing case Piazza
family attorney Tom Klein every
individual who was charged faces
multiple counts each count which could
carry with it one year in in jail
prosecutors say fraternity brothers gave
Piazza 18 drinks in about 82 minutes
during a pledge event at Beta Theta Pi
House in February of 2017
Piazza fell and repeatedly hit his head
surveillance footage revealed piazzas
fraternity brothers waited nearly 12
hours to get help you think that these
boys should go to jail I absolutely do
what's your message to the other young
men still facing charges tell the truth
and why'd you let him die I really want
that answer
Daniel Casey's attorney would not
comment on a conspiracy to commit hazing
charge we also reached out to Brendon
Young's attorney about the same hazing
charge and did not hear back hearings
will resume in Pennsylvania in May my
heart aches for the Piazza Sur scène to
me so much evidence on their side it's a
terrible story yeah it is thank you why